[Musique]
un autre panel politique ce soir on
accueille émilie nicolas hugo lavallée
christian duffau bonsoir à vous trois
écoutez on vous a pas entendu réagir à
la nouvelle vraiment qui marque la
semaine le décès de la reine elizabeth 2
son fils le roi maintenant il faut
s'habituer le port on a toujours
tendance à sur le presse le roi charles
e3 prononcé son premier discours
officiel aujourd'hui il s'inscrit dit-il
dans la continuité oui je serai curieuse
vous entends j'ai commencé avec vous
christian c'est quoi pour vous c'est ce
lien qu'on a avec la monarchie ici au
canada et plus particulièrement au
québec et votre votre vision de la reine
elle était qui pour vous
ben justement vous le vous l'avais dit
la reine en fait que quatre niveaux
c'est le personnage chez l'être humain
et puis il ya les choix unanime main de
poutine zelensky tout le monde s'incline
devant le personnage c'est aussi
souveraine du royaume uni et les
britanniques sont très chanceux d'avoir
une monarchie et puis dans les dix
prochains jours ils vont communier en
fait dans ce qui fait la grandeur de
leur histoire alors que ça va trop bien
au royaume uni sont utilisés ils sont
anxieux au québec au canada c'est autre
chose parce que c'est un archaïsme c'est
clair que pourquoi en fait que le
souverain du canada c'est la reine
d'angleterre c'est vraiment reste du
passé et au québec ça reste un symbole
coloniale à certains égards donc
beaucoup de francophones pour qui par
définition ils vont avoir une vision
négative la règle moi personnellement ça
me demander mon jeu mais beaucoup laruns
moi je mets beaucoup laruns ça me fait
de la peine elle avait de la classe la
veille de la noblesse je trouve que ça
fait du bien bon c'est treize films
armes et quelque part l'étonnante
positif là-dedans parce que c'est un
destin accompli sionisme sans penser
julie juste deux jours avant sa mort
elle a accueilli la nouvelle première
ministre britannique neil strauss pour
passer des points mais c'est parce que
ça nous a pris tant par surprise aux
sécrétions on ne s'attendait absolument
pas à sa mort comme ça s'est
soudainement alors qu'elle était encore
elle habitait encore ses fonctions il ya
deux trois jours
voix se soient pas pris sa retraite
c'est pour ça qu'il faut pas s'attendre
à ce que charles prenne sa retraite
kanté rool c'est un job dans le fonds de
pension c'est donc moi chapeau faux
seins kennedy devant un sommet mais
quand on est québécois c'est sûr que le
rapport est plus complexe non même temps
vous avez quoi vous vivez une sorte de
paradoxe à l'intérieur de vous là dessus
non non non non je parle parle parle à
des gens qui est vu comme moi
personnellement je parle au panel ici
avec patrice j'avais dit je peux être le
seul francophone qui aiment la reine
d'angleterre je réalise l état qu elle
était quand même aimé par beaucoup de
francophones mais prenez exemple sur ma
page facebook moi j'ai juste mis deux
photos une photo d'elle jeunes évitent
toute belle une photo d'elle vieille
jimmy merci va eu des réactions
extrêmement méchantes ah oui qui m'ont
dit christian dufour défendez le
colonialisme et se paiera donc ça fait
partie du portrait emile est votre
réaction à vous
exact
ça suscite des émotions très fortes je
pense pour beaucoup de gens le fait que
qu'elle soit décédée
parce que c'est la fin d'une époque
c'est comme si c'est la fin du xxème
siècle jusqu'à qui était déjà terminée
mais comprenez je pense
alors je dirais le connu la faim la
deuxième guerre mondiale elle a connu
toutes ces étapes et je sais plus
combien de premier ministre et au canada
c'est ça dont elle incarne un peu le
dernier grand personnage politique du
20e siècle mais en fonction des émotions
d afrique des souvenirs de l'histoire
familiale des gens par rapport à ce
qu'elle a incarné dans l'incendié qui
ont un éventail des réactions
extrêmement polarisée je dirais est
forte on remarque un peu partout dans le
monde ce qu'on voit ici au canada en
rien à voir avec ce qui se passe dans la
caraïbe ce qui se passe dans plusieurs
pays africains ce qui se passe au
pakistan ce qui se passe en inde et même
ici au canada entre les anglophones et
les francophones nés population
autochtone les gens qui sont issus des
pays du commonwealth où la
décolonisation était très compliqué il
ya tout un éventail d'émotions puis je
pense que moi ce que je remarque depuis
24 heures c'est que c'est très difficile
de faire des espaces pour tout ça en
même temps c'est très difficile de faire
des espaces pour les gens qui sont
attachés aux personnages et aussi pour
les gens pour qui cette institution
suscite des émotions des souvenirs très
négatif des deux essentiellement de
l'aviron son empire britannique que
c'est comme si on est dans un clivage où
son père de l'un puis on ignore
complètement l'autre ou soit on parle de
l'autre pour l'umih en complètement l'un
alors que les deux font partie de la
réalité puis on veut raconter qu'est ce
que ça veut dire la reine pour le canada
il faudra compter tout ça en même temps
un puits c'est normal dans les premières
heures on soit d'abord sous le choc
c'est comprendre ce qui se passe puis
qu'est ce que ça veut dire pour l'avenir
mais j'espère que dans les prochains
jours dans les prochaines semaines on va
pouvoir avoir cette réflexion sur ce que
ça veut dire la monarchie puisque ça
veut dire l'histoire d'une histoire
d'équipé britannique pour pour le pays
aussi bébé hier des pays de l empire
britannique au coq comme l'un des pays
africains qui ont réagi de façon très
respectueuse à l'égard de la reine
d'angleterre je trouve qu emilie une
vision plutôt négative 10 rue de la
reine d'angleterre allié avec le
colonialisme parce que le rôle que le 8
octobre d'anecdotes d'un moment où elle
joue un rôle positif entre autres pour
les femmes pour les peuples qui était
probable ans donc je pense que tout
était parfait mais la réaction y compris
dans les pays comme de l'ancien empire
les pays donc là s'il vous plaît et très
respectueuse et positif me semble mais
il ya les réactions elles sont
nombreuses et müller a raison de dire à
quel point lampard lequel on peut
prendre on peut citer toutes sortes de
niveau parce que c'est extrêmement
complexe et l'époque elle est tellement
large de spect qu'elle a couvert est
tellement grand parlons des réactions
qu'on a vu ici et hugo je vous inclure
dans la discussion ici la question du
drapeau ou pas en berne ici au québec
alors on a vu le candidat du pq pas
simplement dont réagir très très
fortement d'abord par un tweet où il
répondait françois legault qui annonçait
son intention de mettre le très beau en
berne monsieur st pierre plamondon qui a
dit que bon we love ses condoléances à
la famille mais s'oppose à ce que la
nation québécoise met son drapeau en
berne monsieur legault ne devrait pas
traiter la reine d'angleterre en chef
d'état québécois ni donné de crédibilité
un régime colonial britannique
illégitime au québec il sait le peu
rétracté aujourd'hui c'est à dire il dit
qu'il est toujours d'accord avec ce
qu'il a dit sur le fond mais sur le
moment de le dire par contre il est
nommé loc en fait il convient qu'il y
aurait pu choisir un autre moment est
beau ouais c'est probablement la
meilleure démonstration que c'était un
peu un délit cote sa part la dia les
avec une réaction si rapide pour un
geste qui finalement un tête-à-tête
repas s'y engageant non plus le monsieur
st pierre plamondon a semblé voir un
grand symbole coloniale très important
oui ça fait partie du paysage mais
au-delà de ça il y avait aussi une
volonté de la part de l'état québécois
de saluer ce départ les états unis aussi
ont mis leur drapeau en berne même s'ils
sont indépendants depuis très longtemps
et donc effectivement dans le moment qui
a été choisi dans la manière alors
qu'avait cette unanimité à vouloir quand
même offrir ses condoléances au peuple
britannique va pas très bien paru pour
monsieur st pierre plamondon on a vu
immédiatement sur les réseaux sociaux
beaucoup de réactions fort négative donc
aujourd'hui le réajuster son propos
effectivement personnes croyaient
l'autre paul st pierre plamondon est un
grand partisan de la monarchie
britannique bien sûr ses électeurs
souverainistes ne le sont probablement
pas non plus est-ce que c'était
nécessaire de l'exprimer bluff ou pas
finalement c'est certainement une
maladresse le monsieur st pierre
plamondon ont dit à une très belle
campagne depuis le début les gens
prennent à le découvrir il est quand
même été assez habile peut-être que
effectivement le style à la première
pelure de banane pour lui pense pas ceci
dit que ça avoir un grand impact pour le
reste le tantale en fait monsieur
legault lui a réagi à cette réaction de
pas simplement dont veulent écouter
jean vient pas de ce que fait monsieur
st pierre plamondon il ya
bernard landry dans le temps quand la
reine mère est morte qu'un mac grippe
est morte dans nos landry a mis le repos
du québec en berne que paul st pierre
plamondon viennent faire de la petite
politique avec la monarchie la journée
du décès de la reine elizabeth ii
janvier impôts
qu'est-ce que vous réagissez comme ans
je trouve que monsieur legault en fait
très mal placé pour parler d'une
maladresse des gens parce que cette
semaine il y en ait fait aussi messieurs
que j'en parle c'est maladroit c'est
clair en fait ça fait un peu mesquin qui
ce match et d'avoir de la journée même
du décès d'elizabeth ii je pense qu'il y
aurait trop pédaler ce n'est pas illégal
parce que tout l'univers en fait
s'incline devant subir son âge hurbon
donc mes shows faut pas en faire non
plus de magazines dans la mesure où on
s'entre pas dans un débat soit monarchie
dans la campagne
des places et emilie parce que on sait
très bien évidemment le positionnement
politique de monsieur papa le saint père
paiement dont faire en sorte que l'on
s'attend à ce qu'il ce qu'il suppose de
la monarchie et met ce débat ce débat en
avant plan ça va le servir mais le jour
même de l'annoncé du décès de la reine
de dire on ne devrait pas mettre le
drapeau en berne est ce que vous voyez
aussi comme une maladresse même pour les
gens qui sont ici au québec ou ailleurs
au canada parce qu'il y en a vraiment
aussi beaucoup je pense qu'on réalise
par ailleurs au canada qui sont
intéressés à réfléchir à ckoi le rôle de
la monarchie dans l'avenir du pays
ça va être difficile de pas avoir cette
conversation d'une manière qui va être
qui va être polarisantes manière qui
peut vraiment divisée il va falloir
faire très attention à ses mots pour
essayer de faire évoluer c'était son
leur faire évoluer la façon dont les
québécois puis les autres canadiens ont
un rapport à la monarchie sans s'en
créer quelque chose qui est qui qui qui
qui en reçoit qu'essentiellement puis je
pense que ce qu'on a vu hier c'est que
si on fait pas excessivement l'attention
la manière dont on dit des choses on va
passer par toutes les réactions ça a été
qui a manqué de tact manqué d'humanité
donc ça en fait c'est pas la bonne façon
de faire enfin en communiquant les
choses de cette façon là on se trouve à
se tirer dans le pied de son propre
objectif alors que finalement il ya pas
une chance je pense qu' à terme surtout
parce que la figure de droit chasse aux
noirs ne suscitera certainement pas je
crois la même unanimité la même
admiration parce qu'il ya des façons
dont constitutionnel dont on peut
par exemple avoir le discours du trône
qui peut lier par l'agglo qui évolue par
la gouvernance générale comme ça se fait
déjà au québec c'est le premier ministre
qui les disent construit un ensemble de
choses qu'on peut faire la place de
monarchie sur la monuc sans rouvrir un
débat constitutionnel mais même pour
amener la population canadienne vers ce
sens que ça soit quelque chose qui crée
trop d'émotions polarisantes va falloir
faire avec tact puis ça commence le jour
le jour c'était hier weeks a
raison ça peut être très polarisé le
conte sioniste benoît pelletier nancy
ministre libéral estime aujourd'hui
qu'on aurait probablement référendum sur
la monarchie au canada bon en tout
respect que monsieur pelletier quand
même très limité moi ça m'étonnerait
beaucoup d'anciens même c'est un
anachronisme c'est archaïque c'est clair
c'est normal je trouve que ça dérange
beaucoup concrètement les canadiens et
même les québécois et se lancer dans un
débat là-dessus ça peut être extrêmement
difficile j'entends quel politicien a
intérêt à se lancer là-dedans il s'y
trouvait aussi la boîte de pandore la
cadre constitutionnel si on se met à
parler position il et octo nous devons
arriver le québec doit arriver alors que
le pape prend de faire ça va en parler
c'est clair on va voir comme a pu aussi
bobo bien une chose que la monarchie
britannique actuellement et le l'image
quand même assez positive parce que la
reine chapeau le prince charles son
allocution aujourd'hui c'était magistral
donc pour l'heure les gens alors
concrètement ils vont plaisir c'est pas
normal c'est pas normal mais est-ce que
ça va déranger ce point la mouche fois
sur au québec même au québec cologna
lorsque hugo y aurait aucune aucun
appétit de la part de monsieur legault
aujourd'hui d'aller jouer dans ce thème
là il rit dit le temps gouvernants vont
rester tout reste là on touche à rien
oui c'est un peu le sentiment que les
grandes réformes institutionnelles ont
pas la cote en ce moment les partis font
le pari que ça intéresse pas vraiment
les gens vous avez entendu monsieur
legault sur la question du mode de
scrutin il ya quelques quelques jours
quelques semaines rappelez vous il ya
quelques années on parlait beaucoup du
sénat le sénat canadien qui est entaché
d'irrégularités dans ma smoker avait
promis de l'abolir finalement cette
promesse là non plus avait pas tenu bien
longtemps effectivement comme christian
dit on a le sentiment que finalement ça
change pas grand chose se fait par la
personne il ya d'autres priorités c'est
beaucoup de disco qu'on entend monsieur
legault au premier chef aujourd'hui on
ad'autres cher d'autres chats à fouetter
même signale aussi probablement de la
part des partis fédéraux l'on voit mal
justin trudeau avoir beaucoup d'appétit
pour une réforme constitutionnelle
les conservateurs n'ont plus passé
peut-être dans le rang ou que le plus
fort attachement justement ces symboles
on se souvient de stephen harper je vois
pas non plus beaucoup d'appétit pour une
grande une vaste réforme sur ce sujet
d'un bon on parlait de l'importance de
bien communiquer dans une campagne
électorale belles paroles de monsieur
legault est ce qu'il est dit aujourd'hui
sur le troisième ligne de cet extrait
pour nous le remettre en tête
tant qu'un moyen besoin pour un
troisième levier pour moi c'est comme
une évidence
reste à 10 disent que c'est un pont ou
un tunnel nous on souhaite un tunnel
mais si les études étaient défavorables
à un tunnel vous pourriez revenir un
projet dont on va écouter
actuellement là c'est clair qu'un besoin
bon emilie est ce que vous arrivez à le
suivre monsieur le goal qui nous parlait
dès aujourd'hui deux font soudainement
d'études mais d'études par jour mais qui
vont sortir mais pas avant les élections
qu'est ce que vous comprenez tout ça moi
je veux pas que dans la tête de monsieur
legault mais je me dis si le projet dans
sa taille est extrêmement clair on se
trompe pas en ponctuelles normalement si
le projet très bien défini donc je pense
qu'il ya de plus en plus de pression d d
d autres partis et aussi en fait des
journalistes depuis quelques jours pour
que les études qu'on possède sur le
troisième vient soit révélée au grand
public qu'elle soit rendue publique je
pense que ce qui vient de se passer vos
justes a ajouté de la pression sur le
premier ministre pour rendre ces études
le public parce qu'essentiellement
nouveaux projets on parle de entre 6
milliards 10 milliards c'est pas clair
en fonction des différents scénarios
sont mis c'est beaucoup d'argent public
et on a rien de concret sur la table à
ce stade si je pense que ce qui vient de
se passer aujourd'hui une montre à quel
point il n'y a pas de concret donc si le
premier ministre est aussi confiant que
c'est essentiellement ce qui dit il rien
à perdre a montré les études et je pense
que c'est là dessus que le débat se
concentrer dans les prochains jours sur
la transparence par rapport aux détails
du projet mais tout ceci vous pourrez
jouer le chef du parti conservateur mais
ce duel mais christian aujourd'hui parce
que lui qu'on parle de pont
on le ramène à son projet le pont qui
passerait du côté de l'esl avec un l'île
d'orléans
alors merci mon opinion personne mais
mise mais c'est vrai qu'il dure à suivre
c'est le lot et puis acheté d'accord
avec billy là dessus cette savante que
sa tête ait pas fait à ce point là parce
que si ça pète était complètement leurs
épouses puis moi ça m'étonne moi je
pensais que sa tête était fait qu'on
soit d'accord ou pas je pensais que le
gouvernement legault et fait son lit ce
serait un troisième but et genève donc
c'est dur à suivre un peu notre produit
des cimes à neuf une manoeuvre c'est
comme la lune le projet gnl je suis fier
de ce qu'ils peuvent
y avait vu peut-être des gens pour
ressusciter le projet depuis que
monsieur legault dit non il n'est pas
question en techno gouvernement
manoeuvre que les promesses électorales
ne sont pas aussi nette qu'est-ce que ça
c'est si on veut on veut être décidées
contre x à leur donne de manoeuvre pour
alléger ces ego parce que je veux faire
partie si pires que 30 secondes goût on
a eu quand même droit à tout un exercice
de communication par la suite la part de
l'équipe de monsieur leveaux pour
essayer de rétropédaler de recentrer le
message qu effectivement est en fait
monsieur legault cette fois ci comme un
peu plus tôt cette semaine sur le débat
sur l'immigration est l'artisan de son
propre malheur on estime qu'en forgée
dans ses explications probablement parce
qu'un certain nombre de failles on nous
dit il ya des études on peut pas les
montrer parce qu'elles ont changé mais
en même temps et changeront pas la
décision qu'on va prendre sur le fond
parce que notre idée déjà fait mais faut
quand même refaire les études pour les
mettre à jour il ya quand même un
certain nombre d'éléments le qu'on
arrive au 5e essai va dire tout seul
comme vous venez de le dire le tir des
études qui sont essentiels mais pas
nécessaire à vous de vous les voulez
montrer tout de suite ce qu'un débat qui
prend beaucoup de place dans cette
campagne électorale nationale je pense
certain que ça fasse la sphère de la
carte ans bon ben écoute et emilie
christian gros merci beaucoup d'avoir
été nos panélistes de ce soir c'est un
grand merci